افدى تحقيق لنيويورك تايمز بان الجنود
الاسرائيليين استخدموا القوه المميته ضد
الفلسطينيين العزل في نابلس في 22 من شهر
فبراير الماضي مما اسفر عن مقتل اربعه
اشخاص على الاقل واضافت صحيفه نيويورك
تايمز في تحقيقها ان من استهدفهم الجيش
الاسرائيلي لا يبدو انهم يشكلون اي تهديد
صدق الكنيسه الاسرائيلي في مناقشه اولى
على مشروع قانون يقضي باعدام اسرى
فلسطينيين متهمين بتنفيذ هجمات ادت الى
مقتل اسرائيليين وقد صوت لصالح مشروع
القانون خمسه وخمسون من نواب الائتلاف
الحاكم وعارضه تسعه كما شهدت الجلسه
انسحاب عدد كبير من نواب المعارضه الذين
انضموا الى المتظاهرين ضد مشروع تعديلات
قضائيه تقدمت به حكومه نتنياهو ولكي يصبح
مشروع القانون نافذا يحتاج الى التصديق
عليه في ثلاث مناقشات اخرى في الهيئه
العامه للكنيست واللجان التابعه له